In summer 2018, Arne Duncan published a
memoir. After presiding over nearly a
decade of academic stagnation and the
failure of high-profile initiatives,
there are many lessons he might have
shared. Instead, he seems to have learned
little while in office.
Here are three things Duncan never
learned, but which reformers should take
to heart. One: It's hard to persuade
people you disdain. Duncan shrugged off
anxieties about the Common Core is the
product of moms who fear "their child isn't as brilliant as they thought they
were." Two: It's tempting to ignore
inconvenient realities. Many parents
thought tests were more focused on
measuring schools than on helping their
kids. They had a point! But Duncan
dismisses such concerns. Three: It's easy to
blame bad messaging for policy failures.
Duncan has trouble thinking of anything
he'd have done differently, insisting
that any setbacks were the product of poor
PR. The disappointments of Duncan's
tenure have valuable lessons to teach —
but only if we're willing to learn them.
What lessons do you think school
reformers need to learn? Let us know in
your comments. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.